it's a real real pleasure
to be with you today to celebrate the
pan-european launch
of the new erasmus plus program
the jewel
in europe's crown
erasmus it's the eu exchange program
that some european commissioners love to
imagine as a european institution that
can create perfect europeans
since its start in the late 1980s
erasmus has moved millions of european
students across europe's borders
and in 2021 erasmus plus the umbrella
term for the eu's education program that
covers the erasmus exchange program saw
a substantial increase in its budget
from about 14.7 billion euros spread
over six years to 26.2 billion spread
over another
besides providing opportunities to study
abroad and potentially improving
someone's job prospects the erasmus
exchange program has often been regarded
as one of the most effective
institutions for producing a
pan-european identity
but whether this actually happens is
much less clear than it seems
the creation of a european identity
through erasmus has been coined the
erasmus effect if contact between
different europeans exist than a group
identity will possibly follow
however the problem with this theory is
that erasmus attracts a type of student
that is already less likely to be
impacted by erasmus when it comes to
producing a european identity those
participating in erasmus are already
likely to identify as european before
their exchange making the erasmus effect
relatively negligible
those coming from a lower rung of
education as a result not able to
participate are less likely to identify
as european and are more likely to be
euroskeptic
it's not that erasmus doesn't have an
effect on creating a european identity
but the people who are more likely to be
affected by erasmus are less likely to
be in a position where they will be
however this may also be temporary
last wednesday at the state of the union
urgently on the line announced the eu's
plans for alma a european exchange
program targeted towards the unemployed
the idea of extending european exchange
to a different level besides university
education is not new and it seems like
the tide is turning
the netherlands education levels are
split between mbo hbo and wo mboers
usually pursue vocational education and
are more euroskeptic and wors usually
pursue university and are less
naturally w owers were the ones who
usually did the erasmus exchange but the
amount of mbao students abroad with help
from eu grants has also been increasing
this increased movement has been
encouraged and alexander pechthold the
former dutch leader of de sas incesto
has said that mbo students should have
better access to european exchange
programs europe is no game for the happy
few it needs to show that it's
absolutely necessary for all of us
you can also see other examples like
volt netherlands explicitly pushing to
broaden erasmus plus for mbo and hbo
students as one of their policy
standpoints in the last dutch election
evaluations have shown that the early
erasmus plus program was able to
facilitate a european identity among a
sample of vocational students with 66
feeling more european after and over 72
percent declaring to have a larger
interest in the eu
with the set goal of reaching 10 million
more students erasmus plus over the
course of 2021 and 2027 is set to focus
more on inclusion and the new program is
doubling the funding for vocational
education from 2.9 million to up to 4.4
whether this new more inclusive erasmus
budget plus the additional alma program
announced this year will actually
produce a larger european identity among
europeans who feel that connection the
least
is honestly difficult to determine
but whether this is part of the european
union's goal of producing a stronger
european identity
that's undeniable
our ultimate goal
should be that erasmus
is not become
an option but a fundamental right for
all europeans this new reinforced robust
erasmus plus
will be key
to support
our model of society and our european
way of life
you